happy Mother's Day when I was a kid
Mother's Day meant ridiculous crafts
poorly written cards that only a mother
could love and making an absolute mess
of the kitchen just trying to make mom
breakfast in bed some things never
change but what we are going to change
is that run-of-the-mill boxed crap
pancake breakfast in favor of some
protein packed versions so I pardoned up
with my friends at genuine health to
bring you protein pancakes three ways I
am so excited about this new line of
protein powder because unlike your
typical whey powder
it's made with grass-fed fermented dairy
protein and the fermentation helps you
absorb a better and digestive as well
in other words guys you get all the high
absorption benefits of a protein powder
like way but without the farty bloated
crappy Vitamix see mom I love you and I
love your guts
let's make pancakes first up my gluten
free strawberry cheesecake lemon
pancakes I add one and a quarter cups of
gluten-free oats to a food processor a
blender and pulse until they turn into a
powder then I mix together my powdered
oats a teaspoon of cinnamon one scoop of
vanilla genuine health fermented Greek
yogurt proteins plus powder vanilla
plain fat-free Greek yogurt skim milk
honey lemon zest an egg baking powder
and a pinch of salt I gently mix
ingredients together and allow the
batter to rest for about ten minutes
then I pour about a quarter cup of
batter into the pan and let it cook
now I'm a traditionalist so I'm all that
the round pancakes but if you want to go
crazy pants and bust out the molds and
little smiley face in there for Mom
hey go for it your pancakes your
prerogative so once you see the bubbles
form around the edges I just flip it and
continue to cook it until it's golden
brown on both sides
meanwhile in a food processor or blender
I puree the cream cheese yogurt lemon
zest and honey together and I set that
aside that is going to be our yummy
cheesecake filling I also cook down some
frozen strawberries with a little bit of
honey and water in a saucepot until it's
jammy and saucy then when it's time to
I dollop a few heaping spoonfuls of that
decadent cheesecake filling between my
pancakes and I just doused the whole
thing in this delicious strawberry sauce
next up is my black forest cake inspired
pancakes you start pretty much with the
same batter but - the lemon zest and I
add in a tablespoon of cocoa powder to
the mix I also do the sauce pretty much
with the same technique except where I
use dark cherries instead of the
strawberries and then I sweetened a
little bit of that Greek yogurt with a
touch of honey I layer them all together
and then I chop the whole thing off with
some decadent dark chocolate shavings
and finally my chocolate banana peanut
butter pancakes
these are heavenly so I start with the
same go-to protein pancake mix both out
the lemon zest and then I adding some
mini chocolate chips and some sliced
banana while they're cooking then for my
filling I whip together some Greek
yogurt with some natural peanut butter
and a touch of honey to sweeten and then
I topped the whole thing off with some
more sliced bananas some more chocolate
chips and some salted peanuts as well oh
yeah
it's a good one see the pancake
possibilities are endless so be sure to
leave me a comment below about what you
come up with for your mom and Mother's
Day well thanks so much for watching if
you like what you see of course be sure
to subscribe to my channel and like this
video share with your friends and your
mom and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen